la traversée du fleuve saint laurent à
kano date du début de la colonie au
xviie siècle
c'est alors le seul moyen de traverser
le fleuve entre québec et la ville de
lévis la première course de canot à
glace eu lieu en 1894 selon le circuit
québécois de canot à glace aujourd'hui
la course à canot du carnaval de québec
est la plus grande course à kano du
genre dans la province
ce n'est pas une course à kano mais bien
une série de courses 60 équipes divisées
selon le sexe et selon trois de grid
expertise
martin fleury qui participent à la
course depuis une quinzaine d'années et
capitaine de l'équipe qui a gagné
dimanche dans la catégorie élite hommes
choisir une surprise j'ai pas mais
c'était des bonbons des belles séquences
de baisse surprise qu'ont eue au travers
la course
et puis quand on s'est levé la tête au
milieu de ce troisième tour qu'on a vu
que c'était passé bruisse une belle
surprise meilleur
le grand gagnant toutes catégories
c'était bien la ville de québec elle
même sous les feux des caméras du monde
entier diffusaient dans des millions de
foyers
les images de cette fête de l'hiver
l'image donc beaucoup plus positive de
la ville de québec que celles diffusées
dans le monde la semaine dernière par
rapport à la tuerie dans une mosquée
attendons une grande variété de médias
de corée de chine du japon des grosses
équipes télé de france
la bbc ça va tourner partout à travers
le monde plus de 65 millions de
téléspectateurs typiquement cinq
athlètes sont l'ancien canot et chacun a
un rôle précis un barreur se trouve à
l'arrière
il doit déterminer les grandes lignes de
la course en travers des glaces ensuite
on a les deux moteurs ce sont eux qui
doivent se démener pour faire avancer le
plus rapidement le bateau puis on a les
deux personnes qui vont gouverner
à court terme les petits changements de
direction et ce sont souvent ces deux
personnes qui ont le plus technique
david de didier capitaine l'équipe
on s'entraîne régulièrement là chaque
semaine quelques fois par semaine
toujours à rimouski par contre avant par
le mois de janvier avant les premières
courses on veut s'entraînant québec
pourront plus habiter au courant pendant
lesquelles onze qui en a pas vraiment de
cours qui dit glace dix ou si froid
outre leur veste de sauvetage
les canotiers sont habillés comme des
skieurs de fond et ski sont ici
remplacés par des crampons les bottes en
néoprène
les canotiers doivent jongler avec les
glaces rebelles et bien comprendre leurs
embarcations bien les préparer à la
morsure de l'hiver et au cas sur de la
glace se forme il peut avoir des petits
conflits ça manque beaucoup d'un les
gens sont fatigués ces dizaines leurs
stades bondés gros horaire le des jo le
fait que très demande avec moi je leur
lève mon chapeau font vraiment un beau
travail renommée qui nous est entraîneur
de canot à glace à l'université du
québec à rimouski
si c'est très paisible rimouski on
échange et pour ça on a toute la marina
le temps ne fait pas beau à l'extérieur
on peut quand même s'entraîner dans mary
ne puis on est en dessous des nouvelles
conditions aux glaces qu'on peut
vraiment travailler une technique
travail et les transitions tout
cependant pour le barreur si c'est moins
le fun parce que lui peut pas pratiquer
les trajectoires d'un courant tout c'est
surtout les courses qui sont fort
m'attriste c'est pour ça que on veut
faire faire des courses a dit qu'ils
prélèvent parce que les autres premières
années bon mais il voit c'est quoi des
courses 90 y arriver en compétition et
d'après ou deux ans après et ont déjà bu
c'était quoi
mireille pineau et canotier on a les
entraînements salle d entraînement sur
l'eau qu'on voit trois fois sur le par
semaine de froid en salle donc ça fait
des semaines bien remplies
une autre ville du québec est en train
d'acquérir une réputation internationale
avec la tenue annuelle depuis peu d'une
course de canots réunissant celle là une
vingtaine d'équipés soit trois fois
moins qu'au carnaval de québec
c'est le rif est le festival d'hiver de
rimouski qui a lieu en ce moment même
les vingt équipes réparties dans les
catégories élite masculine élite
féminine et sport doivent effectuer
trois allers-retours entre le quai de
rimouski et l'île saint barnabé un
parcours d'une dizaine de kilomètres
un reportage de radio canada
international